this has gone along quite in a Sweden
has been a peaceful country but not
anymore
now of course I would never incite
violence towards t-series but in a
hypothetical scenario you versus me I'm
gonna show how that would look like I'm
gonna show you guys just how confident I
feel in fighting t-series so there's a
new level on this game called the crab
thanks right crab best castee series I
know that they are crab people and I'm
here to demonstrate goddamn crab people
I'm not racist of course but I freakin
hate crime people the sisters have okay
oh my god I have entered their base what
it is nunchucks
Oh
kondou don't know thanks to what I'm
talking about
you want some you get some good oh shoot
any hope that he's got freaking giant
let's go for the needs what do you want
what is something I to know whatever
quits or towards yo Z fine you know fine
fine it's okay I'm not gonna fight you
I just came to send a message
damnit persistence is a thing few
fighters have so us you're ready to die
salute me I've been waiting for these
my Japanese blades nihongo katana
forgive me but I must go all out you
guys played Minecraft
I studied the blade
[Music]
we just strategy every day sun-ho
nothing
I'm the crab now beat
[Music]
Oh can hate how just one guy shows up
out of nowhere and kills you
this weapon will help you I've got a new
weapon any weapon salute the fight where
is the weapon then Jesus Christ where
where's the weapon wow that is so cool
series you don't know my real listen to
me listen to me listen to me you're sick
you're sick and you need to amputate I
can't say anything Oh God huh don't
think so buddy
this is three then that was cool
that was definitely cool said don't wait
that's what I'm talking about
there are many left to kill yeah yeah
yeah bring them you bring them this what
is that
okay I got it I got it it's a free speed
it's a free speed and a freaking sword
what the hell if anyone come miss near
I'm gonna use the deadly free speed
crush
are you kidding me don't make me use the
free speed the goddamn frisbee sucks
don't make me use the frisbee god
no fresh meat you know what I don't need
anything else
brilliant bring him oh my
ha ha oh God another father in crab
before of God the final battle please
the pipe versus t-series they're
claiming crabs PETA is gonna be so mad
ok bring it
god it's so tiny oh god there's a crime
attack I'm just studying my opponent Oh
God
go away collab go away this is not
personal it ain't personal
yes I got this far now he's other clone
we fight this claw yes hahahahaha come
here no come here
come in daddy wants a hug daddy wants a
hug come here come here
[Music]
oh he's trying to run he's trying to
write him get me get me you killed him
how could you
he was just a bad bad ah
don't hurt her
Oh God
[Music]
this is disgusting I love you but we
have to be like this
I'm sorry you're not good enough well
done fighter to the tender meat of it
raise your hands victory is yours not
until it stops breathing okay I guess
that was a that was it for the crabs I
wanted more crabs are you kidding me
what I'm crying grunting grunting
grunting they will feed off your nipples
they will feed off them oh my god I can
hold weapon ask the crab king oh I'm
giant oh my god
hahahahaha crab cake crab cake crab crab
crab cake hahaha oh it's like putting
petals of a flower does she love me does
she love me not
Oh Oh what you gonna do oh good move
good move
crab cake Greg King
that's right dance for crab King okay
alright punch me as hard as you take oh
wow that was really good oh let me just
Oh Oh oopsie oopsie oh I wanted to get a
hide oh look he dropped a little weapon
look at this cute little weapon oh he's
still alive over there oh you dropped
your food
you drop your little foot let me just
get that cramping is very generous you
know hey buddy
you forgot your foot put it back on
right leg fall prey ding ding well well
well I've been playing for it hope you
guys enjoyed this episode and T series I
hope I explained myself I hope I made
myself clear
crab king for life Craig King rules
all hail crab king see you guys next
time bye tuber simulator it's now so
relevant that it's got a brand new
minigame crania drop the crane and get
fresh items only available in the
washing machine like game and you say
there's more of course there is new
knowledge perks new quests and new pics
links and
guys like